can you can you elaborate a little bit
about
the nature of volatility why is it
communicating
truth that's something that a lot of
people are afraid of is the volatility
almost like it's a it's a sign of chaos
and so they want to escape chaos
but you're saying that that's actually
whether it's chaos or not i don't know
but it's getting us closer to the
fundamental like
reality that we should not be trying to
escape
yeah so if we consider that
the universe is pervaded by entropy
all right this is the second law of
thermodynamics is that every closed
system tends towards
greater disorder over time and that life
itself
again i would argue expressed through
the logos
we life is the anti-entropic principle
it's the only thing that's converting
entropy into order chaos into order
and that's what entrepreneurs are doing
right we're living at the edges of the
known
and we're trying to we're testing
ourselves against the entropy of nature
trying to figure out new and better ways
of saying doing or making things
and then if we do crack a code or figure
something out
we then have a big incentive the
incentive is to get rich right because
then you have a new idea that you could
then sell back into the marketplace
so it's this
sequence of courageously confronting the
entropy of nature
and converting it into good and useful
order which by the way is like the
ancient idea of god in genesis which i
think is interesting
that actually enables us to construct
civilization
in these layers of anti-entropy or order
you might say so today we live in a
bubble of
of anti-entropy or order you know like
the coastlines are guarded by the nation
and the city has a certain
uh police force that keeps it in order
um
even the way we we talk like they're
clearly the
words matter but also the nonverbal cues
all these things are like order that has
been established over
many many many thousands of years of
human evolution
and i think that when i say volatility
is
truth what i'm saying is that the
experience of uncertainty
is something that's inerraticable from
from life right
uncertainty like it's kind of a paradox
because it's we're fighting against it
right we're trying to innovate our way
away from uncertainty to give us to
create more capital
which capital is very simply uh
a way of mitigating uncertainty so this
is why you might have like a stash of
food in case
you know the power goes out or a
generator like it helps you overcome
uncertainty over time
but uncertainty is also where all the
sweetness of life is
so there's got to be this balance with
one foot in one foot out and
so human society is this kind of bubble
of order that we've constructed and
slowly expanding but at the edges you're
always going to have that chaos that
volatility
and that the entrepreneurs are kind of
like
jumping into that chaos and some of them
die
and some of them succeed and so like if
you want to grow
this bubble of order you you have to be
embracing
the volatility at the edges yes
and reverence for entrepreneurship
because these are the people
putting their neck out so to speak
risking themselves
and they're going to contribute to
society by the way whether they go up in
flames or not if they go up in flames
society has witnessed their experience
as something not to do or something that
doesn't work in a particular time and
place
so that you could say they're them going
up in flames is a way of enlightening
the rest of us
or if they figure something out you know
steve jobs
creates the iphone it changes the world
forever so enlightening the rest of us
and celeb would say the fire of their
failure okay yeah exactly
would say um individual
fragility is inseparable from ensemble
anti-fragility
so this means that again every time that
entrepreneur goes up in flames or say a
restaurant
goes out of business when a restaurant
goes out of business
that particular cuisine strategy they
were implementing in that particular
time and place that's a signal to all
the other restaurants in the area that
that doesn't work
so restaurant food improves from
bankruptcy to bankruptcy
so is this this death of the individual
components that contributes to the
growth
of the ensemble
you